I want two dresses Morticia Addams and
drink this we're here to drink golf
lattes
it's a latte that's black like Parcells
I'm assuming what makes it black is
activated charcoal
I'm so confused about this charcoal
thing somebody explained it to me
it's the counter to the rainbow trend
everyone's done with rainbows and they
want these black as their soul
[Music]
Oh
oh that's gorgeous it's so pretty so
pretty
whoa almost like gray it smells like a
latte looks like death this is
unsettling for some reason I I really
like it it's just coffee but it looks
[ __ ] awesome it's like I'm gonna
start drinking Demon Souls
cheers Cheers me the texture is slightly
different there's a little bit more
graininess I mean it's really good
tablespoon of charcoals in this not like
a heaping tables it seems like a lot so
I'm going to yeah I like insist on
holding it like this even though the
handles so small and difficult because I
don't want to cover the awesome mist of
this black liquid we first got these I
thought this was a blue glass but it's
just clear and that's the color that the
latte was yeah it's anything
[Music]
we are in a sort of darker era of
history the darkest timeline and we have
now have a coffee to go with it the
thing I like about goth is it's just a
visual aesthetic goth food looks cool it
doesn't really affect the taste that
much to me
and I'm all for looking as cool as I
possibly can it's got to hold on to that
I know people make fun of all the trends
of like adding food coloring essentially
to everyday foods and making them cool
but I would say there's nothing wrong
with playing with your food and having a
good time and making things visually fun
go make your food art drink your goth
latte yeah enjoy your food enjoy how it
looks to enjoy your life
don't look at off unicloset Laurent mm
that'd be cool I can have like sprinkles
in like a horror there laughs yes okay